yo guys what's up prestige plan here and
you might notice something different i'm
using a texture pack
well um yeah i'm just using goku craft
because i'll get into it more later but
basically i
i messed a bunch of stuff up and the
textures were all funky
and now they're good so
there that's that now
about the video hello all of you people
this is my uh
13th episode of
my hair run survival oh no no oh gosh
okay i don't have a sword it's
um you guys who saw the last episode
blah blah where's your like
the jade or blah blah blah sword
well that's why i need the texture pack
you see i was at
trying to implement tons of mods just to
see what they do and stuff
and
yeah it kind of i kind of ruined my
minecraft
so i had to go
and oh wow he's one hit
i had to go and redownload minecraft
and uh it wasn't fun and
yeah that happened and then i had to i
played the game without the gems mod
then i lost all the gems i had
and then i had to get a texture pack
since all this stuff was invisible
and yeah
so that's what happened and now
i don't have any of the tools i made
with the gems or the gems however i did
pick up some malachite ore
so there's that and i got it done pick
right there so that's cool
so probably going to want another dotted
pick and throw you
in there so we're going to want another
dumb pick
so we need to we're going to want some
wood on us too
i guess i can make a malachite a
sword just
so yeah hopefully you guys enjoy the
texture pack if you don't i'll
turn it off since i think if i turn it
off
like when i spawn in the stuff looks bad
but yeah it's doku cracked i didn't say
it by the way but then when i go back
it's all normal
so i just have to go in at once so i
could do that but i i
personally love the texture pack so
we'll see how you guys like it and yeah
so i'm gonna
work on the farm so i need more wood as
i said
uh i need more than two
that should be good and
make a little less planks i got sticks
iron hoe
yeah so all of the normal texture the
modded textures will just appear
as normal modifications and yeah
so this was the idea i was having before
i was gonna make the farm branch off of
this and actually i was gonna i need my
shovel out
you
okay and then i had uh this here because
i was gonna like
think that's yeah
and i'm just i'm gonna have to place
water in it
so don't cover it up yet
you can make the farm i can make it
branch
where do i want to start do i want to
start like right here
you can go four out so one oh fail two
three four so we can go to there
and yeah so this will be a good start
farm look all nice and cool
and we do want to make it some length so
i'll make it to there
and then yeah i'm not gonna have enough
okay
i want to replace that dirt
blah okay so we're gonna need
hey i'm not not very good at my doors
so we're going to need more fences
and 30 being
yeah 30 should be enough and then we're
gonna need more slabs
uh 30 of those should be enough as well
39
turn on and then we need a bucket
a bucket i don't have a bucket
okay well let's make a bucket then
okay and then we're gonna need to go
with some water
once i get some obsidian i'll be able to
making jam table and i gotta go hunt
down some cows
and let's make an infinite water supply
so that we can
expand i really like this beachfront
property
it's very nice it's very nice
uh let's see if i place you there i
should get
yes i get infinite i can just keep doing
that
oh but i didn't want to do that
please you there
okay this is all calm oh look at all
that water just calmed like
instantaneously
instantaneously
one more nope another one
oh there we go nice peaceful water okay
i think we're i think we're getting
night
night time ish here whoop
i want to finish this walkway
i go in the water yeah it's much easier
make it nice and symmetrical
now finish thank you so it's
one more out
and just take it all the way oh that was
not what i wanted to do
so we need to break this what the heck
what the heck
and we're going to want to destroy this
ground
just give it a little so no one
hops up on here
and let's patch this up
that looks good now
break you pick up all this eat some
meats
cooked pork chop ooh it's like my only
pork chop
now let's try hoeing some ground
there we go
so we have the gems plus modern and
we're all good
still don't know where my hair brown
hair run mod is looking at
so it wasn't like a super famous mod
so the guy probably isn't going to
update it
update it really fast but okay there's
no
that is like no seats whatever i'll
collect some of the sugarcanes
all the sugarcanes let's just turn that
10 off just so it doesn't
use any tools i don't want to
why is minecraft music so peaceful and
awesome
ready for c418 all right let's play some
more of this
thai flour
this will make it go much faster there's
any paper
after this i can sleep and then i can
start
this stuff
you can see the lighting the texture
like ads very nice
look at soapy out of file all right
let's return
return home and turn our switch back on
and i'm i can continue the walkway out
once i get
supplies for it all right we need
torches
not just to keep the mobs away but for
this to grow at night
so let's put it like half like
there that's good i think that's good
and i'm sure oh crap hurting enderman
don't want to mess around with him
especially when i'm at this high of a
level
i could probably really kill him but i
want to risk it since endermen
are freaking annoying okay then
flint flower wow i have a ton of oak
saplings oh my gosh
i always love loving gravel right
because i broke some i'll throw you in
there
dirt uh a couple slabs dirt oh
all these on the other chest there no i
don't i want all that
ah wait already i already have a stack
uh i'll take a stack of dirt and leather
goes in the other chest
let's go we have 13 leather sleep
sleeper time
what do i want to do i could try and
find some
cows
i don't so i don't have any weight to
gather the cows
oh cool i want to pick that up now
someone did suggest
that i make a mine cart into my mind
shaft and that is a good idea
just that on my chat's kind of like one
sec
uh video settings smooth lighting level
50 yes graphics fast fast
i'm just making sure everything is fast
so water fast
fast fast fast fast
i want default um animations
yeah that's good now i think we should
be getting a tad bit better flames
we do have like a jillian chunk updates
um
what the heck is
why is my minecraft so good
is a cow how did a cow get in here
how did you get in here
okay then well that made no sense at all
okay well i'm gonna make a minecart into
my mine shaft
how about we make my mine shaft like
coherent
i hear water in a zombie
what y'all doing
so if i made a mine cart in my other uh
worlds i have another survival world
that i i'm just testing it out
and i need a lot of golden rails like
power rails
to keep its like uh
actually going up the entire time and
why am i not picking up this gravel i
need gravel
luckily one grav pocket gives me all the
stuff
still here in that zombie
so much gravel
oh my gosh
yeah she's starting an animal farm but
for that i need wheat so i need to move
away from my
wheat farm to sacrament and also i'm
gonna be a
carrot farmer since carrots are the best
plant in this game
one cara revives two while three wheat
or vibes two and a half so
just putting that into perspective uh
let's patch it up with cobblestone
sir it looks like poo
um i hear water i kind of want to
hit up that water what's how
are you
oh there's my pick new pack
let's have my torches out oh water
getting closer
it's like option sound
there it is torch
uh gonna want an easier way to get up
so we'll want to block this water
okay now we gotta be on the lookout
for creepers and zombies
damn creepy zombies torch
oh there we go
i see light oh torch my torso goes over
i there i'm pretty good on gravel i hear
that zombie heart
oh that was a fail spring jump splint
jump photo v
iron i'll take that
now
[ __ ] i'm wondering
where are the other gems since i do want
some gems i found some gems
gems gems value
for are you well though
i have no idea how long i've been
recording
i should really get some better ways to
figure out how long i've been going i
should i should
i know how to find out
15 minutes oh dang it looks like the end
of the episode
all right well uh
i kind of want to go another five
minutes all right this will be a longer
episode
20 minute episode yeah put the one
i need to continue on this staircase
since i need to get down to mining level
of uh diamonds and the other goodies
i'm near caves and sure that little
ambient noise
i do need obsidian
i need to break these blocks that's what
i need to do
i'll pick up that coil later i don't
think i should break into the block side
i ain't dying
enough
i should break these ones though fail
didn't mean do that
oh
pop
what the heck okay that was weird
here bad but
batman
f3 i'm at 37 so i'm still pretty high up
still pretty high up well once i get to
a low enough level i can start making
like strip mines that branch out and
then i can find caves and then like
my mine cart will go down to the bottom
of this and it'll be quick
to find caves and stuff
oh is this a little cave there's a
little another
to die up it's just just a hole
for hairbands making them holes bro
i think that is a trailer around making
little holes i think i thought it was
tunnels two by two tunnels
yeah i thought it was
thought it was
my pick is gonna break soon how about we
go to my pick break let's get it let's
get playing right
right i think it's a good plan
oh hello cave
i was a ravine oh just cave this
gold gold's cool
oh dang huge cave
everyone everyone just calm down i got
this
now i'm not seeing other ores so i don't
know what's up with that
i better not have to move in i don't
want to move again
i like my house it's nice
it's not wanting him to blow up
i want to pick up that gold
let's
no bad
okay here's spider freaking out got a
bunch of iron
get some more gold gold
come to me
oh that's a lot of zombies oh there we
go there's the
okay yeah there are no um
wait yeah that stops the game
texture packs default
maybe for some reason the other ones
aren't showing up wow i could see so
much more in the
oh no i could see so much more on the
other uh
texture wow
this is so weird
um i'm not seeing any of the other oars
i'm definitely gonna have to do
something about that
after i do this i'll go around just to
make sure the order there
if they aren't
someone's gonna get his turn to all i
can do
hello baddie you see like you can't see
anything like that just the lighting the
other
one like there's so much more of it
okay what i would go now in the midst of
big cavern
die i hope you all enjoyed this episode
if you did make sure to leave a like a
comment and if you're new subscribe
it's always awesome to have another
person enjoying these videos
so i will see you guys later
have a cool spring break
and where the heck are these other oars
ah peace out